If you type left brain versus right
brain into YouTube, you'll fall into a
vortex of wild claims that creative
people are right brain, that analytical
people are left brain. For decades,
[music] pop psychology carved the brain
into two neat categories, logical versus
creative, analytical versus emotional.
The idea became so oversimplified, so
pervasive that serious scientists
abandoned the entire field. One
psychiatrist who decided to study the
divided brain was warned by his
colleagues,
>> I was told when I got involved in this
area, "Don't touch it. It's toxic. Don't
even go there."
>> He went [music] anyway. And what he
found was nothing like the YouTube
version. The two halves of your brain
don't do different things. They do the
same things, but in different ways. And
that distinction has enormous
consequences for how we learn, how we
judge right from wrong, how we see
reality itself. In this video, I want to
show you the real science of the divided
brain and why one researcher believes it
explains something troubling about the
world we've built. Let me explain.
Iain McGilchrist is a psychiatrist who
spent years studying the brain through
case studies and scientific research.
His book on the topic, The Master and
His Emissary, has been on my radar for
years. And it all begins with a question
that's much older than pop psychology.
Why is the human brain divided into two
hemispheres?
If the brain was simply a processing
machine, why split it in half?
And yet the division is ancient. It
shows up in mammals, reptiles, fish,
insects, even nematode worms with just
302 neurons have brains that work
asymmetrically. One of the oldest
creatures to have a neural network is a
tiny organism [music] called
Nematostella vectensis.
It lived about 600 million years ago.
Its neural network was asymmetrical.
Whatever this division does, evolution
has been betting on it since long before
dinosaurs [music] walked the earth. Now,
whenever we want to understand why the
brain is constructed the way it is, it's
helpful to start with noticing what the
brain does as we go about our lives.
Think about a little bird trying to pick
up a seed on the ground.
>> Uh all living creatures need to be able
to attend to the world in two different
ways which require quite different
attention at the same time, and this is
simply not possible unless they can work
relatively independently. On the one
hand, in order to manipulate the world
to get food, to pick up a twig to build
a nest, you need a very precise,
targeted attention on a detail uh in
order to be able to achieve that and be
ahead of your competition.
But, if you're only doing that, if you
were a bird just concentrating on the
little seed, you'll become somebody
else's while you're getting your own
because you need at the same time to be
paying the precise opposite kind of
attention, not piecemeal, fragmented,
and entirely detailed, but sustained,
broad, and vigilant for predators and
for other members of your species.
>> Two kinds of attention. One, narrow and
focused. The other,
wide and watchful.
Both running at the same [music] time.
If you only have the narrow view, you
eat the seed but get eaten by the
predator. If you only have the wide
view, you can see danger coming,
>> [music]
>> but you starve. The brain needs to hold
both views of reality at the same time.
And this is where the pop psychology
version falls apart. The two hemispheres
don't carve up the work with one
handling logic and the other handling
creativity. Both hemispheres are
involved in everything. The difference
is how they approach it.
>> The reason that we got things wrong in
my view is that we were looking at
simply the functions as we saw them and
divided them up in much the way that we
would if we thought about a machine.
This part of the machine does this, this
part of the machine does that. And if
you instead of using the machine model,
use the model of this is part of a human
being, a person, you would ask a
slightly different question, which is
not just what does it do, but how does
it do it? And that turns out to be a
profoundly important question when
looking at the hemispheres because they
both involved in doing everything. But
there is a difference. It's that quite
consistently each hemisphere does all
these things in a totally different way
with a different kind of spirit towards
a different end, if you like to put it
that way.
>> A different spirit to what a different
end.
>> [music]
>> The right hemisphere takes in the whole
picture. The left zeros in on details.
Both are essential. And the way they
[music] work together is more
fascinating than either one alone.
>> Imagine you are attracted to a piece of
music and you try playing it as a whole
and you you love it. But you realize
that there are bits that you are not
getting right. So you know you need to
practice your fingering at bar 18. And
when you're taking it apart, you
realize, oh, here we move into the
subdominant. At this point we're moving
back to the dominant. You you [music]
understand a whole lot of details, which
are fine. You need to do the work and
you need to do the analysis. [music]
But when you come to play the piece, you
must put all that out of your mind,
otherwise you won't be able to play at
all. The right hemisphere takes in the
whole at the start. The left hemisphere
unpacks that and enriches it, but then
that work being done, it needs to be
taken back into the whole picture, which
only the right hemisphere can do.
>> The whole first, then the parts, then
back to the whole. For this
collaboration to work, the hemispheres
need to both connect and stay separate.
The bundle of nerve fibers that links
them, the corpus callosum, has long been
described as a bridge passing
information freely between the two
halves. Iain says it's more like a
gatekeeper.
>> In order to collaborate, you need to
both work together and work separately.
If a surgeon collaborates with the scrub
nurse, they don't both try and do the
same job. They have distinct roles. And
the corpus callosum enables both
separation, mainly I believe separation,
but also connection.
>> Mainly separation.
Without that boundary, the two views of
reality would blur into one, and the
advantage of having two perspectives
would be lost. In 1997, PBS aired a
documentary about a patient named Joe
who had severe epilepsy. His doctors
devised a radical treatment. A surgeon
sliced Joe's corpus callosum, literally
[music] splitting his brain into two.
The surgery stopped the seizures, and it
gave researchers a rare window into what
each hemisphere could do on its own.
What they found is that the differences
between the hemispheres run much deeper
than just attention. Take language. Both
hemispheres process it, but the right
hemisphere tracks tone, implication,
what's not being said. The left
hemisphere is more focused on the
literal words.
>> Language has many components. One of
them is attending to the tone of voice
in which I say something. For example, I
can say, "Yes." Or I can say, "Yes." I I
can intone that in probably a dozen
different ways with quite different
meanings. So, for example, I say, "It's
a bit hot in here." You, using your
right hemisphere, know that what I mean
is, "Could we have the door open? Could
we put on the air conditioning?" But
your left hemisphere is wondering
meanwhile why I'm supplying this quite
unnecessary meteorological information.
>> The right hemisphere understands
context. The left hemisphere is more
literal. It's the weather report. This
extends to everything implied,
everything unspoken. Humor, for
instance, requires you to hold multiple
meanings at once, to grasp what isn't
being said.
People with right hemisphere damage can
find it difficult to understand why
something is funny. The same split shows
up in moral reasoning.
Iain describes a wonderfully vivid
experiment. Picture two scenarios. A
woman is having coffee with her friend.
She puts what she thinks is sugar in her
friend's cup, but it's actually poison.
Her friend dies. Second scenario.
A woman is having coffee with someone
she hates. She puts what she thinks is
poison in the coffee. It's actually
sugar. The other person lives. Which
scenario is morally worse? Most of us
would unhesitatingly say the second.
Intent is what matters. She tried to
kill someone. But when the researchers
temporarily disabled part of the right
hemisphere,
>> the right temporal parietal junction,
which you can do with a painless
procedure, and ask people to solve moral
problems, they give quite bizarre
answers to them based on entirely
utilitarian understanding of them.
>> To the left [music] hemisphere, what
matters is that in one case, someone is
dead on the floor.
It's the worst outcome.
It justifies the harsher punishment. The
fact that it was unintentional requires
seeing the bigger picture. When someone
steps on your toe in a crowded elevator,
your left hemisphere and your right
hemisphere have a conversation. Your
left hemisphere says,
>> [music]
>> "This person stepped on my toe. I need
justice, maybe vengeance."
"Hang on a second," [music] your right
hemisphere says, "the elevator is
crowded. The person who stepped on your
toe wasn't looking. It was an accident.
Chill out." Language, humor, moral
reasoning, three things that make us
most human, and the left hemisphere
struggles with all of them. But, here is
where the story gets darker.
The left hemisphere [music] cannot see
the big picture, but because it believes
that what it can see is all there is to
see,
>> [music]
>> it doesn't know that it's missing the
big picture. If a person suffers a
stroke in the left [music] hemisphere,
the right hemisphere remains functional.
The person knows that something is
wrong. They're aware [music]
of their deficits. But, when the stroke
hits the right hemisphere, something
disturbing happens. The person can have
no idea that anything has changed. Ian
describes an exchange between a doctor
and a patient who had right hemisphere
damage. Again, that means her ability to
see the big picture has been diminished.
Her arm was paralyzed, but she wasn't
aware of it because her left hemisphere
believed that what [music] it can see is
all there is to see.
Producers from our show performed the
exchange that Ian described. The
physician asks the patient about her
non-working arm.
>> Whose arm is this?
>> It's not mine.
>> Whose is it?
>> It's my mother's.
>> How on earth does it happen to be here?
>> I don't know. I found it in my bed.
>> How long has it been there?
>> Since the first day. Feel, it's warmer
than mine. The other day, too, when the
weather was colder, it was warmer than
mine.
>> Her own arm, attached to her body,
and her left hemisphere working alone,
came up with a self-contained story that
her arm was fine,
but her mother's defective arm happened
to find itself in her bed.
>> Well, what we're seeing is a phenomenon
called denial,
which is a feature of the way the left
hemisphere works. So, if you have a left
hemisphere stroke, so your right
hemisphere is still functioning, you're
very aware of what deficits you have. If
you have a right hemisphere stroke, you
are completely unaware of there being
anything wrong.
So, if you
have a paralyzed left arm, which is
often a consequence of right hemisphere
stroke, more often than not, you will
deny that there's any problem with it.
If I was to move it, you will say there,
but it didn't move. If, on the other
hand, I bring it in front of you and
say, "Whose arm is this? Can you move
it?" They say, "Oh, that's not mine.
That belongs to you, doctor, or to the
patient in the next bed, or as in this
cat, my mother." It's extraordinary, cuz
these are not people who are anyway mad.
They They They don't have a psychosis.
But, they're simply incapable of
understanding that there is something
wrong here that involves them.
>> The left hemisphere doesn't just see a
narrow view of the world. When evidence
contradicts its view, it confabulates.
It invents a story that fits what it
already believes. The right hemisphere,
meanwhile, can see what both hemispheres
are doing. It recognizes the value of
the left. It understands its own
limitations. Think about this as you
watch this video. To process what I'm
saying, you need your left hemisphere.
It hears the words, makes out the
meaning in them. But, I'm not just
spewing words. I'm trying to paint a
picture, to tell you a story.
If you're a writer or a creator
yourself, perhaps you're noticing the
way this narrative is unfolding.
But, to see this, you need to look
beyond the words and sentences. You need
to go from processing
to understanding.
Iain offers an analogy that brings this
idea to life.
>> And, I sometimes give the analogy of,
you know, a scientific approach to what
is music. And, a conventional scientific
approach would be, "Well, let's drill
down and see what it's made of."
And, after uh years of expensive
electron microscopy, I can inform you
that music is made up of notes.
Uh what is a note?
A note is uh
a simple tone. What does it mean?
Actually, it means nothing. Well, let's
take another one. That was an A flat.
Let's take a B.
Doesn't mean anything. Now, if you put
35,000 of these together, you've got the
B minor mass. Where does it come from?
Well, it can't come from the notes cuz
we've established that they don't mean
anything. So, it must be something else,
but all the rest is gaps. It's the gaps
between the notes, the gaps that make
melody, the gaps that make harmony, and
so on.
But, the gaps are just, as it were,
silence. They don't mean anything,
either. So, if you put lots of things
together that don't mean anything with
lots of gaps that don't mean anything,
you get something that means everything.
>> The left hemisphere hears the individual
notes. Notices the gaps between the
notes. The right hemisphere
hears Bach.
Feels the glory in a piece of music
written more than 200 years ago.
Now, you can draw the wrong conclusion
from what Iain is saying. He is not
saying that the left hemisphere is
unimportant. You wouldn't be able to
raise your spoon to your mouth without
your left hemisphere.
What he is saying is that the left and
right hemispheres of the brain both have
important roles to play, but in an
increasingly busy and deadline-driven
world, we have come to prioritize the
left hemisphere, and we have come to
devalue the right hemisphere. We
celebrate accomplishment and
achievement, but we fall short when it
comes to understanding and meaning.
Iain's book is called The Master and His
Emissary.
The title comes from a parable about
power, knowledge, and the danger of not
knowing what you don't know. The parable
comes from Nietzsche. A wise spiritual
master rules over the land. He cannot be
everywhere at once, so he appoints an
emissary, a bright messenger to carry
his instructions to the far corners of
the kingdom.
>> And this emissary was bright enough, but
not quite bright enough to know what it
was he didn't know. And he thought, I
know everything. And he thought, what
does the master know sitting back there
seraphically smiling while I do all the
hard work? And so he adopted the
master's cloak, pretended to be the
master, and because he didn't know what
he didn't know, the result was that the
community fell apart, essentially.
>> The master in Ian's analogy is the right
hemisphere. It sees the whole picture,
understands [music] context, holds the
meaning.
The left hemisphere, it handles the
details, executes the tasks, breaks
problems into pieces. The emissary is
essential. Without it, nothing gets
done.
But the emissary cannot see what the
master sees.
And because it doesn't see the big
picture, it assumes
there's no big picture to see.
>> [music]
>> Ian believes this parable describes what
has happened to modern Western society.
He argues that we have built a world
that listens almost exclusively to the
left hemisphere and dismisses what the
right hemisphere has to offer. So I
asked him, "What would a world that only
had a left hemisphere actually look
like?"
>> Well, obviously we would lose sight of
the big picture. That's the thing I've
emphasized throughout. There'd be an
emphasis on on the details instead.
There would be a great emphasis on
predictability, organizability,
anonymity, categorization, loss of the
unique, and uh an ability to break
things down into parts, but not really
see what the whole is like. There'd be a
need for total control because the left
hemisphere is somewhat paranoid. And
that's because one can't understand
quite what's going on, and one needs
therefore to control it. Anger would
become the keynote in public discourse.
Everything would become black and white.
The left hemisphere needs to be decisive
because don't forget it's the one that's
catching the prey. It's no good going,
"Well, yeah, it could be a rabbit, but
it might not be." It's got to go, "I'm
going to go for it. So, it likes black
and white. It doesn't like shades of
meaning. So, in this world we would lose
the capacity to see grades of different.
We would misunderstand everything that
is implicit and metaphorical and have to
make rules about how to achieve it.
>> Black and white [music] thinking,
putting algorithmic calculations on a
pedestal,
forgetting nuance and curiosity. Does
any of that sound familiar? Look around
you. Do you see examples of people
racing around without knowing where
they're going?
Building things but not understanding
what they're building or why?
>> I think what I observe is an
overemphasis on predetermined
systems of algorithms, the sense of
social alienation, the way in which we
live divorced from the natural world,
which is a very new phenomenon, the
insistence on extreme positions, which
is what the left hemisphere understands,
not a nuanced argument about the pros
and cons of every single thing.
>> Extremism instead of judgment. Life
divorced from the natural world. Rules
for everything. Hmm.
I wonder where we can spot those things
these days.
>> Meaning comes out of living in a
consistent culture where there is a
sense of connection with one's past and
and not just one's own past, but the
past of the people who made you who you
are, with the other people in the
society to which you belong, and to the
world at large, the natural world, and
things that are just simply beyond our
ken, the transcendental.
These are very important things that the
right hemisphere's much better equipped
to understand, and I feel that the loss
of them in modern life is grievous.
>> Iain is careful to point out that this
is not an argument against science or
reason. He loves science. He depends on
it. The argument is about balance. The
hemispheres need each other. The problem
comes when one of them forgets that the
other one exists. He ended our
conversation with a line sometimes
misattributed to Albert Einstein.
>> The right hemisphere sees the need of
the left. That's in the image of the
master and the emissary. The master
knowing the need for the emissary. The
emissary not knowing the value of the
master. And if I may use a quotation
from Einstein, I think this gives us the
full picture. He said that the rational
mind is a faithful servant. The
intuitive mind is a precious gift. We
live in a society that honors the
servant but has forgotten the gift.
>> We have forgotten the gift.
That line has stayed with me since my
conversation with Iain.
Because the story of the divided brain
is not about one half being good and the
other being bad.
We need the emissary. [music] We need
its precision, its focus, its ability to
break things into parts. But the master,
the part of us [music] that sees the
whole picture, that understands context
and meaning and what is not being said,
that part [music]
has been pushed aside. And most of us
don't even realize it's gone.
Because as Iain's research shows, when
the left hemisphere loses something,
it doesn't mourn the loss.
It denies there was ever [music]
anything there to lose.
Thank you for watching this video. If
you've come this far, you are someone
who is fascinated by the mind. You're
curious and interested in learning more
about ideas.
Check out the Hidden Brain podcast on
your favorite audio podcast app.
Each week I'll teach you something new
about your own hidden brain. I'm Shankar
Vedantam.
See you soon.